like I love that I can call my like we  all know as women and maybe maybe you  guys are better than me my my air  pressure light is always on my oil has  never changed my my smoke alarm battery  will always be beeping and am I it's  like when the men come around and  they're like how are you living like  this like my dad will like run around  you're smiling I bet you can think of a  time where someone's done this right and  they'll just fix everything and just be  like why are you doing this and it's  just something like comforting like I I  feel better like if I'm stressed or  whatever I just love talking to my dad  and my brothers like there's just  something about talking to like  masculine men where it's like you just  feel better